welcome back to cbs mornings on this
thursday morning a surfer is recovering
today after being bitten by a shark off
of new york's long island it happened
yesterday and we do point out that these
bites are rare though they almost always
involve
an adult shark at some beaches in
southern california though swimmers
surfers and businesses are adapting to
life with juvenile great white sharks
which are spotted all the time there
carter evans has followed researchers
studying the sharks for years now and he
shows us what they're learning about the
shark's
impact on local communities
stunning images of great white sharks
sharing the water with swimmers in
southern california's busiest beaches
are now a common sight it's these drone
views that have really changed our
understanding of how sharks behave
around people chris lowe director of the
shark lab at cal state long beach says
the juvenile great whites here are up to
seven years old and mostly ignore people
but sometimes they get curious it's no
different than a neighborhood dog right
you're out walking with somebody and the
dog comes over and gives you a sniff and
in fact if you do make a move toward a
shark
they tend to go the other way exactly we
see this over and over again we
witnessed it last summer this shark is
just swimming so calmly and so
gracefully right now and taking it in
the beach now
which is why i'm now comfortable enough
to get into these shark-infested waters
with lowe's research team they had me
help swim a massive fishing net to
researchers on the beach there you go
where they capture and tag some of the
sea life the sharks might be feeding on
and low says people just aren't on the
menu
but on the rare occasion a shark bites a
person it makes national news the
swimmer was badly injured today in a
shark attack for a shark attack
following a shark attack the shark lab
now wants to understand how all of this
is impacting local economies a couple
years ago we had a woman that was bitten
i was at a city council meeting in
huntington beach and i heard that there
was a seven million dollar loss in hotel
reservations but there's also evidence
shark bites can have the opposite effect
with more people becoming shark
enthusiasts a west virginia university
study found an initial increase in hotel
bookings three days after an attack but
after that the bookings drop
this all comes down to people's
perceptions exactly economist d.d long
is working with the shark lab to study
the financial impact some people might
think oh i take this really seriously i
don't want to go to the beach but some
people might think oh this is really
exciting i actually want to pursue this
opportunity
at this santa barbara beach it's now
common to see a dorsal fin break the
surface offshore
hello shark
but the sharks aren't hurting business
according to surf shop owner sam holcomb
when i educate the stand up paddle board
renters about the sharks very few choose
to not go when people are on the beach
sharks are pretty far down the list on
their list of concerns tourism professor
katie dudley is working with the shark
lab people come out here they go whale
watching can you see a day when people
come out here and go shark watching oh
absolutely that's why this team is so
great and unique because we're coming at
it at every different angle so that
hopefully we can make a truly
sustainable model to help have a
thriving tourism destination right next
to a thriving shark population in our
oceans
and there are so many of them here the
sharks are easy to spot i found one he
is right on the water this is the same
area where we were just swimming that
net to shore so we just saw our first
shark of the date i'm gonna get on the
paddle board and we'll go see if we can
find him with the shark lab team
watching oh he's right there he is
literally right here we found a great
white shark close to nine feet long wow
look how big he is but as we try to
verify its length next to my paddle
board look how close to shore we are
look his fin just broke the surface
right there we discover my balance could
use some work the shark
is right there just zip out 10 feet off
we are joined now by carter evans uh
limbs and extremities still intact i
guess carter uh you got back on that
balance board pretty quickly uh you okay
you know it's a hard habit to break i'm
a surfer right so i've got to accept
that if i want to do the sport i love
then i'm going to be swimming with these
animals and so i've got to learn to
change my perspective here but listen i
wasn't messing around there these wild
animals have to be respected i wasn't
going to get so close because my balance
is not great on those boards i was not
going to get so close that i could fall
on that shark because yeah it probably
would bite me if i fell on it so that's
something that people should know you
should stay away from these animals and
again
these are babies they don't look like it
but they're babies they have not learned
how to hunt large mammals yet they're
going to turn the other way when they
see a large animal when they are adults
and they're feeding on seals you don't
want to be around
well it's very different when you're
scuba diving
when you're underwater when i'm scuba
diving and i see a shark it doesn't
matter what species it is you're totally
fine you're totally calm because you're
in their habitat exploring it the same
way that they are but if it's when
you're on the surface or when you're on
a surfboard that you see one that you
get a little nervous because they do
these sneak attacks where they come from
underneath you and game over i don't
know i know these researchers are trying
to they're trying to change the
perception of sharks right they call it
like a neighborhood dog but like there's
just something about all those rows of
teeth that i just really can't get
behind and carter when you fell i was
like i needed you to get back on that
like you're right hurry
it's not the neighborhood dog it's more
like a stray you don't know that dog
dog might be dangerous but they are
immensely fascinating and wonderful
animals carter and i'm glad that you're
educating the people the public about
that because they're not they're so
misunderstood and people don't really
have a full understanding of them so
thank you carter thank you very much
it's a great piece